collected by Kane Andrew cop brings
back in finds Kane thrs behind the
net in front AER the goal line save on
Alex to Brink it hold modest pass for
R hon he touches it for sprung he's got
speed taking on hin in and got the shot
away was forced wide AER made the sa it
now out in the circle flip down low score
spr the Red Wing strike first just over 5 minutes
into the game opens it up for Detroit well the
first defending work by mirro Hain and it's
terrific the stars get full control but suder
can't handle the four check in the corner and
that that is just a hard fletcherizing for check
that pops a puck free what are you going to do it
happened so quickly from the top of the circles
down and spraw who scored 21 for the Kraken last
season gets kept alive hin in pass broken up not
cleared up by Harley Stars work at Haskin and
that rings off the crossbar partially fanned on by
Detroit extends the pressure from Dallas Jamie Ben
behind the net he'll flip Robertson hin it R shot
score hin and gets the power play goal and Jamie
Ben's going to collect his 500th career assist
on the play at one and this was an assault they
came close three times they had scoring chances
set up never got a shot on Rhymer and then
ultimately it was Ben just dropping anchor
in front of the Detroit net minder Meo hkin and
shot from distance Ben just bodyb moider in front
of the net he couldn't block it it sail you get
that that's the international POS of I'm really
screened from sets up this attack Zone draw they
win it h and with a blast was blocked the other
way come the Red Wings spraw feeding left Circle
a shot save Baleno denied this time slides into
the star Zone hackin paw pursued by Brink it besid
mismatch somehow even grows in that exchange cross
the line steel final second they score Lindell
they'll check the clock as Lindell looks like
he got a buzzer beater to sneak in and give
Dallas the lead have been some lengthy gold
droughts for Dallas defenseman and one of them's
over ess's is not as as long as some others this
is going to count and cars right in off the
pipe with 2/10 of a second to go I don't know
what happened to Rymer on that one whether it
dipped or something but he he looked like he
was Raymond off the stick Robertson
becomes a turnover Peli shot it
wide that was a mess now over to
Robertson he clutches and scores
that was polish and professionalism took his
time found his spot went upstairs on Rymer
and Jason Robertson doubles the Dallas lead on
their way in they they couldn't quite get things
done yeah and the Ripper by pavelski catches
the window from that they rck what a gap Red
Wings all out of sorts both defenseman convers to
the first of the net sherro and Petri and Rymer
looked as it was coming off the netting over
his shoulder and back out again up and over
the crossbar but the Stars hunted down there
it's duain taken on sprung this time overlap
from Sean Joel Hanley holds it in from the
line shot score do Shane look to get a piece
the Stars add another here in the second
they've opened up a three-goal lead this
all started with Tyler San's Primacy on the
forj onong you know he hustles after it here
dislodges the puck from the wing forward and
the way they go in their cycle sth goal of the
season for Matt du Shane it snaps an 11 goal
drought his longest since February 2017 you
can tell from the reaction how nice that one
felt he was on a four-game goal scoring streak
just before that shot save rebound score be
grd gets one right back and Jonathan berren
has Detroit back on the board he scored some
goals in in his NHL work they come right back
here with an answer goal to keep in touch of
the score rebound of a shot dead on I'm sure
Jake aringer is thinking I'm spitting this over
into the corner no problem it surprised Yanni
hacka fell perfectly for berren 15 now 16 goals
in 72 NHL games is not bad you haven't noticed
him that much noticed to Brink it but not him
as much five on five spread out by the wings
cop in front save by AER on the doorstep
rest M then Fox a blocked a shot stung him
cider opening 100 seconds have coming
gone here in the third period settled
by fiser sprung centers chance and Andre
with the glove denies gustus bear what a
stop this had sass in it the entry andley
in the Box third power play of the game for
Detroit feels like a must have for them they
are down by two to break it in front Veno he
scores he took that first whag at it unable
to find it got to it on the second this looks
like the exact same play they had set up
back in the second period with res m in
front of the net valeno just peels back opens
up that cross crease pass shot ends up getting
stopped momentarily but it dribbles in essel
andell can't get up underneath of the stick
and get and they've been on a run ever since
this would be a large tally here if they can
get it the Stars control the face off hinan over
to hence in front tip score oh my surgical Joe
pelski it took a handful of seconds the Dallas
power play has two they get it right back and
they're up by a pair my God Perfection put
this in the Jean Jones art collection in
Arlington this is a masterpiece of high slot
deflection perfectly located Jamie Ben again
making a door of himself in front of the goal
as the wings carry out Rymer gets to the bench
again it's now a conventional five on four
look for the wings they turn it over steel
written off by valeno Steel fights to get it
back and it pops out for hkin in empty net he
scores it's the second goal of the game it's the
third point of the night for Meo hinan and Dallas
is going to ride up off with another Victory
against the wings these are known as blister
goals all the work was done by Sam steel the
hustle and tenacity and Puck pressure and dig
to win they handle the Red Wings here pick up
their sixth straight win against Detroit 11th
straight over them in this building double up the
wings and get their 16th victory of the season